[Música]
y avanzamos con la economía directo
América ya Jorge Hurtado está listo en
el estudio Jorge seguimos hablando de lo
que pasa en Rusia y Ucrania cómo
reacciona la economía de luego de la
escalada ese conflicto en los mercados
mundiales sobre todo con el precio de el
petróleo internacional rondando los $100
también el gas y por supuesto la energía
al alza pero parece que estos son apenas
el inicio de una Hola un efecto dominó
que está ocasionando el conflicto en
Europa del este Los Embajadores de la
Unión Europea se reúnen para discutir un
plan de sanciones contra Rusia también
está por verse como reaccionará Estados
Unidos y sus aliados Y si esto lo
definen como una invasión los mercados
energéticos se mostraron al alza hoy
luego de semana sosilando en cada subida
de tono entre occidente Moscú Europa se
enfrenta a una crisis de suministro de
gas que ha hecho que los precios se
cuadro impliquen en el último año el gas
natural europeo lideró Un aumento de
hasta 13% por los acontecimientos los
futuros del gas holandés que son una
referencia europea subieron 5,9% a 76,85
€ el megavatio hora también el carbón
europeo subió un 4,4% en la actualidad
Rusia es el mayor proveedor de gas para
Europa un tercio de sega viaja por
gasoducto que atraviesa en Ucrania Rusia
también es un proveedor de todo tipo de
productos desde petróleo hasta metales
por su parte la dependencia Europea de
la importación de gas es enorme su
producción interna apenas cubre el 10%
de la demanda de modo que el viejo
continente deberá Buscar proveedores
externos para abastecerse el canciller
Alemán o las choles anunció el bloqueo
de la certificación del gasoducto ruso
alemán 2 una decisión que Reino Unido ya
anuncio que también apoya Así es Jorge
petróleo también alcanzó su nivel más
alto desde el año 2014 debido a estas
atenciones entre Rusia y Ucrania
cancelación del suministro está
empujando los precios cerca de $100 El
barril El crudo Brenda referencia
mundial aumentó 3,38 o un 3,5% se ubicó
el 9877 esto tras haber alcanzado antes
99,50 el máximo desde septiembre de 2014
por su parte El crudo estadounidense o
es Texas subió 4,40 o un 4,8% se ubicó
de 95 $ respecto al cierre del viernes
tras haber alcanzado los 96 $ el
conflicto entorno Ucrania añadió más
presión al mercado del petróleo que den
aumento por la escasez de suministros
mientras la demanda pues pandemia
también se comienza a recuperar la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo y sus aliados conocidos Como
Opel mantienen cautela por aumentar la
oferta el ministro de petróleo de
Nigeria dijo hoy que no es necesario que
la ope aumente la producción de petróleo
en lo que va del año te quería agregar
el aumento ha sido de un 27%, ya me
estoy adelantando porque este tema pues
me apasiona a Jorge cómo reaccionan los
mercados bursátiles frente a toda esta
situación bueno comenzamos con Rusia
precisamente el índice mox de Rusia cayó
hasta un 9,2% así como el rublo que bajó
un 0,5% frente al Dólar las acciones
rusas sufrieron la mayor caída de marzo
de 2014 y ahora cotizan con la
valoración más barata Por su parte de
los rendimientos de los bonos rusos a 10
años aumentaron hasta 40 puntos básicos
y superaron el 11% los mercados
asiáticos cerraron en negativo por las
pensiones geopolíticas el índice de
referencia japonesa el Nike cayó si es
1,71% se ubican los 26,449 por su parte
las acciones surcoreanas registraron su
peor sesión en una semana el índice de
referencia
cospi cayó 1,35 y en Europa las acciones
europeas alcanzaron mínimo de 7 meses
antes de recuperar algunas pérdidas
presionadas por las perspectivas de
duras sanciones contra y hablando de
sanciones varias economías mundiales
también están ya diciendo Cómo van a
Pues digamos castigar a Rusia por todo
lo que está pasando Jorge Bueno Estados
Unidos y Francia ya han prometido
sanciones contra Rusia por los últimos
acontecimientos mientras el Primer
Ministro del Reino Unido por Johnson
anunció sanciones contra cinco bancos
rusos sí 3 millonarios cercanos al
gobierno ruso esto últimos ya han sido
también sancionados por Estados Unidos
vamos a escuchar qué dijo antes también
el ministro de finanzas de Francia
si el presidente Vladimir Putin va más
allá nos reservamos la posibilidad de
intensificar las sanciones en función de
las decisiones que toma el presidente
putini
Viole impunemente el derecho
internacional en esencia se cuestionan
los compromisos internacionales la base
del orden internacional las normas el
principio de soberanía el principio de
inviolabilidad del territorio y del
espacio territorial de Ucrania
bueno Jorge muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información económica por
supuesto muy pendiente eso mañana a lo
que siga ocurriendo en relación al
desarrollo de lo que pasa con estas
tensiones vamos directo a París
[Música]